moins d'une dizaine de villes dans le
département des ivelines ont fait le
choix de la semaine de
4,5 jours réforme scolaire bien sûr nous
allons en parler la commune la plus
importante dans les Yvelines en terme
d'effectifs à être concerné c'est celle
de trappe nous en avons déjà parlé sur
cette antenne la contestation est
d'ailleurs forte et ce soir c'est autour
du conseil municipal de trappe de
s'annoncer plus ou moins agité il se
déroule dans un peu plus d'une he si
vous nous suivez en direct il est
bientôt 18h 18h30 Nicolas hardi le
président du mouvement autonome unap
regroupant des parents d'élèves prévoit
une intervention il est avec nous en
ligne ce soir Bonsoir à vous Nicolas
hardi bonsoir comment va se dérouler
tout simplement l'intervention de ce
soir lors du conseil municipal bah déjà
va se dérouler dans le calme
j'espère nous avons demandé donc une
interition une interruption de séance
afin de pouvoir prendre la parole et
effectivement expliquer au conseil
municipal notre position et pourquoi
alors quelle est justement cette
position aujourd'hui que vous défendez
avec ses parents d'élèves
alors de deux remarques on a
effectivement une première annonce avec
une réforme du rythme scolaire pour
l'année 2013 ou 2014 et une deuxième
annonce qui s'annonce pour l'été 2015
avec une un passage à 38 semaines donc
mise en place d la rentrée 2014 faire
deux réformes de années de suite pour
moi ça va ça va déboussoler les les
élèves deux années du site donc autant
faire les deux réformes sur une même
année et dans ce cas-là on aura une je
dirais un comment dire excusez-moi euh
on aura une pour ça simplifierit les
choses ne serait-ce que que pour les
enfants au moins qu'ils aient une seule
et même réforme pendant que vous parliez
on a vu quelques images d'un reportage
que nous avions réalisé il y a une
dizaine de jours lors de l'annonce
justement de ces décisions de la mairie
vous nous dites que la prochain la
réunion le conseil municipal qui va
s'entamer et votre intervention sera
calme pour autant il y a une dizaine de
jours les parents étaient plutôt
remontés les enseignants également
contre cette décision de la Ville de
trappe aujourd'hui vous sentez que les
esprits sont plutôt sereins parce que
une fois de plus vous nous dites
l'intervention de tout à l'heure dans à
peu près une heure à trappe se fera dans
le calme je
l'espère quels sont les les remonté que
vous avez sur le terrain plus
concrètement moi je je tiens à dire que
les le comportement auquel on a eu droit
mercredi est quand même
irresectueux on a eu des parents qui
devaient être qui étaient là pour avoir
des des réponses alors résultat ils sont
partis sans sans information et enfin
qui était complètement anarchique et
irrespectueux donc vous allez faire une
intervention avec des propositions lors
du la séance du du conseil municipal la
municipalité a été informée d'ailleurs
de votre présence tout à fait quelle
réponse vous avez obtenue d'ailleurs du
maire bon on aura la réponse ce soir
vous n'avez pas eu encore d'éléments du
tout on sait on sait effectivement ça
travaille que visiblement il y
a il y a des des régularisations qui se
font sur le dossier mais rien rien ne
filtre parce que la ville avait annoncé
qu'elle ne reviendrait pas sur cette
décision de de 2013 de septembre 2013
pour la
réforme mais si si la ville décide de
rester sourde ben nous on continuera le
mouvement h et il est clair que je pense
les premiers concernés enfin ceux qui
savent le mieux ce qui est bon pour
leurs enfants c'est les parents une
dernière question vous nous dites
annoncer des des propositions aussi lors
de de cette réunion quel type de
proposition vous allez faire déjà vous
nous disiez regrouper les les deux
réformes les deux les deux modifications
de 2013-215 sur une seule et même année
mais est-ce que vous allez proposer des
horaires également tout à fait
on d'abord on conteste effectivement le
l'heure donnée par la ville en en
faisant commencer les élèves à à midi à
9h excusez-moi oui il y aura un décalage
d'une demi-heure c'est ce qui a été
annoncé pour la rentrée au lieu de 8h on
reste nous on reste sur des horaires à
8h30 11h30 h en rallongeant la pause
méridienne de 1/art d'heure donc il
ferait 11h30
13h45 et une reprise de cours à 13h45
jusqu'à
16h le le rallonge la rallonge du la la
pause méridienne nous permettra de
mettre en place des activité qui devait
déjà en place depuis le passage à 2h de
cette pause il y a quelques années et la
mise en place d'un temps calme pour les
élèves après le donc 16h 16h ça nous
laisse un temps pour mettre
éventuellement les APC le un goûter
d'une demi-heure pour les élèves qui
fréquentent l'étude et une une étude au
moins de 1h30 mais qui soit réellement
dirigé voilà pour les propositions que
vous allez faire tout à l'heure lors de
ce conseil municipal à trappe ce sera
dans à peu près 1 heure he je vous le
disais si vous nous suivez en direct ce
soir 22 avril conseil municipal qui doit
débuter vers 7h30 merci Nicolas hardardi
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous nous
reviendront bien sûr he sur cette
information dans notre édition de demain
sur cette action de l'Association des
Parents d'élèves indépendants lunap nous
en pararlerons demain